okay so you're at on the set of eating
your feed eat your feet the show where
Adam the man behind the camera
challenges us schmoes to recreate a
viral food from the video from the
internet okay so today we're looking at
a video from June's kitchen he's a
youtuber in Japan that does a lot of
food content he's made sushi for his
cats he's kind of he has majestic cats
Wow the knives the two of them do you
think they're related what is that what
is that the cats are just like sitting
on the counter watching and I really
love that this looks hard
what okay he chopped up fish he chopped
up chicken he did something to the
chicken in the coffee maker I think that
was bonito flakes oh those are burritos
yes he's making like a little hydrating
bonito flakes to make a type of bra I
think that might be pretty important to
get a cat senses engaged in it do cats
know a bonito flakes are they no fishy
smell Wow okay then he's got one of
those sushi boxes and he's pressing raw
tuna into it and slicing it up like
sushi
oh okay so those goo balls are acting as
the rice in this season okay like one
bite his paws just in there like give it
to me
should we talk about her cats a little
bit I would love to his name's rice ball
he's a munchkin cat and he's my best
friend
other than that no my cat is named
Wellington mm-hmm the birthplace of my
fiance you see you opened this canna
where once you were like talk about your
cats they're gonna be here all day
unlike the video our cats are not with
us today to watch the cooking process
they would be too scared in this
environment so I think we should chat
with our random cat today our friend ray
[Laughter]
you've seen the video what is gonna be
the most challenging for us because at
this point I don't even know who
chumming whole fish you need a Japanese
dip a knife okay I think we're gonna
need your help when it comes to
butchering the fish I'm very scared for
my fingers today thank you Ray
yeah see you soon go play with all of
our fingers so I think we should get as
close to a whole fish as possible she is
too different
we need a light fish and we need a tuna
very fresh only the best for my cat same
chicken
edamame bonito flake the siphon yeah but
really careful here yeah we have to be
super good this is like these are our
babies we got stuff oh wow you can
really smell the fish I don't like that
well you know who does like it cats so
we've got our chicken or edamame bok
choy there are a lot of things that cats
cannot eat do your own research before
you feed your own cat I think we should
begin by oh that is stinky taking apart
our fish okay clean hands and our friend
hi what's in the box my friend Cory let
us borrow a dip a knife corn is where we
filmed for were ther chef's knives this
one is used for the cheering fish it's
very sturdy so you can cast it a fish
bone it's got like that nice like angle
on it thank you makes me nervous that
it's so close your face I know as long
as I'm holding ya tips also how do you
fillet a fish we have it here oh yeah
that also teaches everything so this is
our sea bream oh it does have teeth you
know what those kind of look like rice
balls teeth okay so what are we gonna do
first remove the face of the fish
there's a head go for it Niki
yes Wow yes there you go open Yoona up
here and then cut here and you kind of
want to meet in the center yeah oh I see
I see yeah yeah yeah yeah oh wow it is
so sharp oh nice
yes yeah watch your fingers
I know I know old old and go
we moved from the spine yep there you go
uh yeah I was hard now we have to take
the skin off right
didn't he take the skin off I think so
yeah you're like our cat that's watching
us but way more helpful ha a little bit
yang CJ okay and you can be just like
Celia no I can't
yeah I screwed it up definitely I just
keep going cuz this just ends up being
that little like mountain that's served
next to the sushi right well I didn't
get quite as much meat off the skin I'm
gonna take this regular knife and just
scrape mine while you're doing that okay
okay oh my god going back to our regular
it's nice that one is so hoarse sure
yeah you seeing them doing next we can
process our chicken we clean the cutting
boards we clean the knives we clean
their hands everything is clean we're
being very meticulous this is for my son
so next we can do our beans and our
little bok choy leaves there's one a two
three four how many does he have look we
can make a little boat and put our
little bee wow this is fun okay stop now
we can do chicken where is it oh those
are big the only way we could get skin
is if we bought the bone as well if I'm
doing extra steps for my kitty
he's a precious boy so I will work
harder to give him everything he loves
to have like toys and food and treats
like that song it's very good do you
call him your son no
well okay so there's our deboned breasts
we gotta get to a real small mince it's
so sharp we're taking all day to prepare
this for our cats I don't even think I
ever cook all day for myself you want to
hop in sure this is not what this knife
is designed for but June doesn't in his
video and it looks so satisfying it was
look very fun
sorry Koren what do you think I think
we're there time to steam
oK we've assembled our mashed up
ingredients okay I pre boiled some water
to speed up the process great should we
just plop the balls on yeah pop them
balls on lid on order up
yeah we're gonna let this steam for
maybe 15 minutes we check on it in ten
sure you know what you really how we
really like don't have to worry about
overcooking here no cats prefer
overcooking 140-150 what do we want to
be 165 at least again we can't really
overcook it you just really don't want
to undercook it don't touch it stop
touching it I love to fiddle I know I
know
with fiddler I know thanks do you want
some of the spicy rice snacks how spicy
are they not that spicy weren't these
the ones that Annie ate like a whole bag
of last year and it was just like in a
world of pain yeah she threw up she did
good right
Altice swears it for me Patrick one for
the record books
that's how you make sushi for cats okay
we're good can we use the siphon now oh
yes let's make our dashi dashi
so these are the bonito flakes we got oh
that smell yeah a real kind of use this
one it's actually extremely mild no are
you lying to me to get me to eat it not
I kind of like it it is like very very
smoked salmon oh this is the most
science we've ever done boom I feel like
a hamster with this thing so from what I
can tell you put coffee grounds in the
top bowl sill the instruction manual
we're making fish broth do not use for
purposes other than making coffee
all right we've had a little bit of a
kerfuffle with our fuel situation so as
a alternative we're gonna use this
butane hot plate
yikes lock and load this Thank You
flakes how many does he put in the video
I'm checking now floor oh that's a lot
too much how about now alright at first
why cuz that's what he does see it's lit
oh it's filling with the water oh he's
just like blasts up that whoa oh this
seemed unnecessary but like really fun
not gonna lie that kind of looks like
pee
oh wait very looks like be careful oh no
we gotta chop everything up do you just
choppy choppy until it no it's quite
hard now it's a little upsetting Oh
the combination of smells yeah you could
fart right now room smell it's so dry
your legs can't possibly overcook this
you can turn this into a face I'm gonna
give you all of the props all I've ever
wanted was props okay what if I tried to
roll this into a tiny little ball I mean
it's sort of keeps a shape that's not a
total failure still so crumbly quite
this makes me nervous
oh okay more liquid house oh wow can you
do a little ball roll oh yeah nice job
thank you thank you things ready to give
up see you like that looks close to what
he did right you ever caught your cat
eating something weird he likes to eat
fluffs like if there's just like a
random like fuzz on the floor he'll like
sniff it and then eat it before we can
grab it up how about you hold definitely
chew on a hair tie that's on the ground
Oh rightful loves house I may have made
this one too wet I'm gonna combine they
do
I ruined it Nikki's canopy man rice you
betrayed me
[Music]
yeah I can't believe that's all the fish
we got out of that whole fish that's
shipping Damon more chopping this whole
video is just chopping okay I think I
created a pace oh wow it's a little
crumbly but it looks so much like wasabi
it's too wet
don't use that please no that's much
better okay time to do the tuna
hold your knife up and let's say it at
the same time three two one tuna time we
bought sashimi grade tuna it even comes
with a little packet of wasabi should we
eat some right now I don't really want
to let me to squirt it right on or well
squirt it right on there you go you know
this means you're my cat this is just
like a knife skills video okay yeah well
we're getting there it's getting very
pasty you wanna give it a go
sure whoa kinda way he does in the video
it looks very effective
now I'm worried that we're ruining the
night it's like a little play-doh type
situation
whoa well it's not quite big enough what
is really like fold it in half like that
I mean a lot we just need it to look
like sushi well thank you she Cuba we
can always try and if it doesn't work we
can just shape it like we're shaping
everything else yeah that's that's bad
that's bad okay
it's a bit too thick I think okay those
are fine yeah so we're just doing a
little shaping on these you know he ends
up with something kind of thick not too
dissimilar from that those yeah and I
think it's time for assembly yeah maybe
we should invite reate to watch
okay we have mushed beans mushed fish
steamed and sliced bok choy leaves moist
chicken and mushed tuna and and pea it's
dashi but the last thing we need is our
test cat Wow it's beautiful yeah rice
into a like sushi shape mmm technique
technique make eye contact do this
technique my tuna a little bit of the
edamame look like wasabi - right that
goes on top rush of dashi Wow it's
beautiful yeah I'll stand in the center
please oh of course
as is your right hello it's not welcome
tell me nervous
you got this just remember to look me in
the eyes and say technique then you'll
be golden how's that feel squishy it's a
little like moon sand but wet so I'm
distracting me I'm making sushi from my
dad okay so he kind of doll up of that
flops that on there little brush of
dashi I'm just gonna do a little gentle
I think this side maybe looks better we
have enough for two more why don't we
make two more that we could sample it's
not often I get to eat the same food as
my cat is okay if I don't eat it yeah
you know I'll be insulted you have to
get it with the chicken okay
you know what I'm actually not mad at
that flavor kind of good their taste is
nice no you have it's not that weird oh
it doesn't taste bad but the texture is
upset okay just from the visuals I feel
like we did a pretty good job yeah
end result versus June's like his is
obviously more refined but I'd say yeah
like 80% of their ones sushi to go for
my cat good luck text me about how it
goes here's my sushi and here's the
right
[Music]
if I just like break up a little piece
you don't want a Wellington there you go
[Music]
there's a lot of food sushi
[Music]